hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse this is Jesse and today we're
going to test out Keystone Jas I've
never used Keystone so I don't know if
it's gonna work I don't know how this is
gonna go this is for our our big project
project 5 which would be the main
website for the university that I work
at we've already pulled some data and
put it into a WordPress database so my
sequel and that works and we might end
up lewin with that but I thought it
would be worth it to test out a
JavaScript based content management
system so that we could be full stack
JavaScript so that's we're gonna do
today I I could see in the live chat
here Harshit is worried about graph QL
in it and I was a little bit too so I
found on github that somebody had
already set up next yes which is what
we've been using with graph QL and
Keystone altogether now I don't know
that I would like you know everything
about the way they did it but for today
I think it's worth it just to use what
they've done to get us started just to
see if we like it no sense in trying to
customize everything early on if you
know we're not even sure if we're going
to use it if anybody knows of an open
source headless JavaScript CMS that we
could use I'm still open to that because
Keystone is not maintained as far as I
know let me pull over on my screen some
some info about Keystone so I'm going to
switch views here
okay so let's check this out okay so
something was changed a month ago
so yeah it's not I mean some of these
are two years ago yeah
the let the latest release came out in
May of 2016 so you can see there's been
some other stuff going on but it's
really like I don't I don't know how I
feel about using something that that
seems to be not actively maintained
anymore there's some activity but I'm
just not I don't know we'll look at it
we'll take a look at it and we'll see
we'll see how it goes so this is what I
thought I'd use now obviously this is
not a popular repository right we've got
eight stars two forks but what this does
do is it uses you know the three things
that we're already planning on using now
to be to be honest I don't care quite as
much about them using next because
that's all going to be decoupled but it
does have this which is what I what I
really care about graph QL with Keystone
so let's try it out
we do need I do need to make sure that I
have the latest version of [ __ ] which I
don't remember if I do or not so let's
show this out
I'm pretty sure I have done this
recently I'm I'm probably don't have the
latest version
hmm
oh cool Harsha's saying I can just
homebrew homebrew is like a project it's
like a package manager for your Mac
alright so let's try this out I asked
you some stuff my Lodge had Andre asked
if I'm Canadian
no I am NOT Canadian so it doesn't wrong
with being Canadian but I was born in
West Virginia here in the United States
okay
what's the what's the package from long
ago
okay I found it
I think I've run a brew update recently
but no reason not to run it again
seems to be taking a while alright I'll
let that go
alright cool I went through alright so
if you're just joining we're getting the
prerequisites ready to install Keystone
so all right cool I was just installing
[ __ ] and it looks like I I did already
install this so I just need to upgrade
all right so
I'll let that go now why
let's clone this and it looks like I
have everything else I need we're to
clone this and again I'm just doing this
to get up and running as fast as I
possibly can with graph QL and Keystone
basically I just want to see how easy is
it to add new post types and to navigate
the editor and the CMS I know there's
already a demo online but I can't get in
there and you know see the code and
change it like I'd like I want to go
question Hissam says what is
collaboration on github is there
something on github called collaboration
I don't know I'm not sure who saw is
anyone else know haven't answered the
question what is collaboration on github
and less you mean collaboration in
general I'm not sure if you could
clarify for me maybe I can give you a
better answer
all right still not quite done with
homebrew installing [ __ ]
all right great so we have [ __ ] there
now let's do a git clone and I'll add
this
should I fork this first yeah let me let
me fork it first and then I'll have a
repo I can make changes and I don't know
how long we'll be testing this out it
would probably be better
so let's find this fork it into here
well it was fast awesome ok now let's
let's clone this one
John John B John B said I should spork
it's pork it will let you fork the repo
but also spoon it when you're feeling
lonely
what is my job' I'm gonna remember that
one and use it at some point in the
future if you don't mind I need to find
my SSH passphrase and LastPass
it's
all right and I think we've done this
before but if you get asked for your SSH
passphrase and you don't feel like
typing it in again if you just do SSH ad
and hit enter it'll ask you for it again
and then if you put it in then it won't
ask you again
at least until to restart your computer
I think if you restart your computer
then it'll ask you again but at least
for that session you'll be you'll be
fine
I've got harsh it says brew services
start MongoDB hard [ __ ] do I just need
to run it like that like later on when
we need to use it or do I need to do
that now all right so we have this we
have a clone let's go what does that
called Keith done there we go let's run
yarn get all this stuff installed ok
Harsha says I need to run that command
now brew services start MongoDB so I'm
gonna copy that and when this is
finished we'll run that as well
thank you huh [ __ ] oh cool Blake said
the SSH ad worked so awesome I'm glad
glad it worked it is useful to you know
also I have a meeting at 3:00 so this is
going to be a short stream I really hope
I don't forget about my meeting at 3:00
I'm sure that someone one of my bosses
will come in and knock on my door if I
do forget and they won't be happy all
right I wanted to start the stream
earlier but I was updating my computer
to the latest Mac version so it is it hi
Sierra and it took way long
then I thought it would take so and then
when I finally got a restarted things
were so slow at first so I did not get
the streams scheduled earlier like I
wanted to
now some air is coming up I hope this
isn't this isn't gonna ruin the install
I see huh
well that's no good hmm
all right I should saying that that fork
is old oh man I hope it's not too old
okay so hard saying maybe she's trying
to install things that don't even exist
anymore well that may have just ruined
my plan here and all right let's shoot
all right this isn't the only Keystone
graph QL repository that I found so let
me just find the other ones that I had
open and we can check out another one I
mean I really don't know which one is
better so I just happened to pick this
one suddeniy did something all right
Oh Roger said been running Linux for
years and never heard of SSH ad Thanks
oh you're welcome cool well if I can't
get anything else to work at least I was
able to share that that little helpful
bit with you all so I'm trying to adjust
the screen I think I kept going I keep
going off screen I can't tell which way
all right that's that seems like it'll
work
all right let me I can't find the window
let's see what is that all right maybe I
closed it
and III really wanted to have this ready
to go so we could just you know go
quickly since I don't have a lot of time
but it looks like it may not happen
Keystone graphic uh
okay it looks like Keystone Jay s the
organization ki-sun jazz on github
actually has graph QL helpers there but
it looks like everything's two years old
not sure how helpful that's gonna be
all right well let's um
alright let's just go with something
else
oops
I had all that there's some things in
the live set let's see what's what's
going on here my freelance project first
prototype can you give me any
suggestions the freelance project is
using next accustomed graphical server
and Apollo client and server-side
rendering yeah hard [ __ ] sure I'd be
happy to give you suggestions on that so
just let me know where that's at if I
mean I'm assuming you have a repo for it
so just you know send me that link you
on Twitter or whatever and I'll try to I
probably can't take a look at it today
because I'll have a meeting and then I
have to leave right after that but at
some point this week I can definitely
take a look at it
all right I should saying let's just use
word WordPress Roger says every time
someone publishes a PHP website a kitten
dies wouldn't we wouldn't want to kill
kittens right now as it said it is truth
yeah yeah horseshit I'm the more I am
the more I try to look into these
different JavaScript alternatives to
WordPress the more I keep thinking we're
just gonna need to go with WordPress
like it's just all right listen
everybody who's interested in a side
project I think there's really a need
for a JavaScript CMS that is open source
basically the JavaScript version of
WordPress right so if anybody really
wants a side project that could
potentially be adopted by a lot of
people make JavaScript WordPress I
certainly don't have the time to do it
but I'd be happy to help so all right I
don't think we have time to do it before
this project is due
but potentially we could work on it
longer-term and then try to switch over
to it at some point with this project
all right so enough enough of me talking
let's see hey hey Stephen and jewel
let's ju le i'm assuming that's
pronounced jewel if it's not please let
me know and I will do my best to
pronounce it correctly harsha's let's
make this together using graph QL
suggests same for just mentioning you're
gonna check
strappy CMS I have never heard of
strappy CMS listen Ethan cakephp and
have it to check out strappy blade all
right Blake says go to Keystone comm
slash getting started that's where that
was actually just for us about to go the
only reason I didn't want to do it
before is that they're they're getting
started guys as you use a yeoman
generator which I haven't used yeoman
for a long time
I don't even know if I have it installed
on this machine I'm not opposed to using
it just to get things up and running it
would probably be pretty fast but I
don't know we could I'm checking out
strappy right now on my other screen
[Music]
I'm checking out their github repo
they are definitely way more up-to-date
they have things that have been updated
just a few hours ago it looks like let's
see yeah it's all JavaScript that's a
lot more stars here 18 issues
well you can work with whatever database
you want which that's awesome okay I'm
I'm definitely gonna look into strappy
more alright we're probably gonna do a
stream tomorrow on strappy today let's
just use this you haven't generator
install this thing just to see how it
goes right because I named the stream I
said in the name of the stream that that
we're going to use Keystone I even put
their logo in the thumbnail for the
video so let's at least install it and
mess around with it just a bit after
after this whole mess here with getting
air is trying to use this I I'm not
confident but where's my I know I had
the getting started here we go oh my
started yo man yo Keystone do I have you
I don't think I have you installed
anymore
hey I do have um an installed awesome
get me out of here okay yo Keystone
and they're not the generator yeomen
Keast all I need to install a donut
there was another getting start there
yeah this one is like the super easy
version of the getting started there we
go
install generator
Keith done there we go I'd spend years
since I've used Keystone I didn't or
since I've used yeoman I did not even
remember that she had to install the
generator first yeoman used to be
amazing they back in the day I remember
being so excited about it but and then
it's just like nobody used it no could I
just say no whatever um definitely SAS
if I'm gonna use one why not sure let's
escape everything you should enter an
email address
temporary password the same plane takes
two changes through this
what what is going on
I don't know what password I just gave
that Shh yes new directory Okemah
configurations sure
I don't want any of this stuff yes
that was a lot more questions than I
thought all right let me see I'm gonna
catch up with the live chat while I last
installing
now rook said I know nothing about it
I remembered the name don't kill me if
it turns out bad no so far it looks
really good so that's awesome thanks for
that okay it was already mentioned by ad
lib hi oh I must have just missed it
when it was mentioned before so sorry
that I missed that
and then indoor ojs calm
okay so Blake says there's an enduro j/s
calm which has a nice full screen video
here a section check that out
nice alright let's check this out that
myself is documentation
cool Isis has themes in it this is like
oh wow this actually does look like
JavaScript WordPress
actually if if we wanted to make a
front-end to coupled with this I would
probably go with this I think was the
other one
strappy strappy looks better just from
like the five seconds that I looked at
it and a little bit of time I looked at
this oh I'm gonna really check out
strappy for this project but if I were
to do another project where I wasn't
trying to have a headless CMS this one
looks really nice not bad
okay large it's saying ghost is the most
popular CMS for JavaScript
I've heard about those before but I've
never used it
okay so ghost is like a
subscription-based service right Wow
finally
all right let's check it out
okay so we act we have a Keystone
Keystone site going alright so this is
not the latest version so the beta these
like the 4.0 beta of Keystone was
supposed to be built with react at least
for the admin panel I think and this is
not this is not react this is jQuery and
bootstrap so let's check it out I think
if we type in Keystone that's how we get
to the backend yeah all right so
I don't know what my password was I was
first getting email about it so this to
me shape my email yeah
maybe I didn't I thought I was going to
but it's possible that I that I didn't
see ok cool harsh it says you can
actually host ghosts yourself that's
that's cool oh cool john b note the
password is admin awesome thanks john b
i tried to change the password but it
didn't work so i guess it ended up being
admin i was just gonna make it 1 2 3 4
cuz all right that seems like a good
password no one would ever guess that
creating new foes it's actually really
fast
I mean it's running locally so it should
be fast so I guess it's not a good test
yeah I mean this I really wish is just
the beta that says it's the beta okay
you know what this this is the latest
version because the back end is running
in react they're still using jQuery
which is weird but hey I mean we
I vote aside with jQuery and react so I
shouldn't didn't say anything I actually
had built two sides like that yeah
before when I checked that wasn't the
admin area so I was mistaken
all right well I'll tell you what here's
my take on Keystone if if you are
looking for something to run a small
site that's like probably not for a
client and you're you know you're not
that worried about it that's not there's
not a lot on the line like it's not an
e-commerce site or something like that
I think Keystone's pretty cool it's nice
especially like if you want to use it
headless I mean I don't know if I would
want to use the the full CMS with with
the front-end coupled to it but I guess
you could it's so if you don't mind that
it's probably not going to get updated
often and I don't know if there's any
support with it but the backend seems
super easy to use and to customize this
it's all JavaScript so I think this is
actually kind of a cool thing if you
want to take this almost as a
boilerplate customize it on your own
there's little chance that an update
will come out and mess up which you've
done right so so I think that'd be cool
to just fork it and customize it to do
what you want with it I mean I assume
it's MIT license I guess we could check
yeah it's MIT so you could do you know
you do whatever you want with it I mean
who knows maybe there are Forks out
there that that are being updated that
are awesome
but I don't think it's the right thing
for our projects I really kind of hoped
it was especially since there were
already some built in graph QL things
out there that people were doing but
ultimately I would say probably the main
reason that I don't think we're going to
use it now is just the lack of updates
you know as I said you know there were
some updates a month ago you know but
it's likely not you know it's not
maintained
you said the first
actual release you know the major
release was was over a year ago
about a year and a half ago and although
there are some newer things here in the
beta you know even the newest thing was
October 23rd and then before that was
all the way back in January 25th so that
that bothers me a little bit you know
this isn't you know this isn't just a
side project website this is the main
website for the university this is by
far the most important project that I've
worked on since I've started here so I
don't know if you all disagree on on
that assessment of Keystone for this
project please let me know in a live
chat or in the comments or even you know
Twitter direct message whatever you want
so I think it was worth it to check it
out so we're a little bit more familiar
with it I was kind of impressed at how
easy it was to start if you use that
yeoman generator I mean that was really
really fast and we have it all up and
running you know I mean potentially you
know you could throw in some posts here
publish this thing and you know you you
have a website with that you can have
users with admin panel all that you know
you have it up and running in you know
less than an hour depending on how much
content you want to put on at first so I
mean that's impressive
that's really impressive so this is one
of those things like I really wish that
this had been maintained more because I
think it's you know this this is still
pretty cool even though it hasn't been
updated in a while yeah so I think if if
this gets maintained or update or
somebody takes over on a fork this could
be really cool but anyway probably not
going to go with this and now it's a
great time for me to stop go to the
lives
answer some questions because I'll have
I have a meeting in less than 20 minutes
anyway so this stream may be turned out
not exactly what I how I thought it
would but we still got to try out
Keystone so if anybody's interested in
it at least you know how to at least the
easiest way that I've found to install
it and that is the recommended way with
yeoman all right so let me go to the
chat now and I'll answer any questions
that you have so you have questions put
it in there if we end up going too close
to my meeting I will have to stop so
there's a possibility I might not get to
all the questions but I will do my best
to answer everything see so let's scroll
up a bit that I think I did miss some
things
okay Blake asked earlier about what I
mean by headless CMS and horse she gave
an answer but I just want to kind of
answer on the video in case you're
watching later I think that's that's
probably a common question I apologize
for just using that term without
explaining it so a content management
system like something like WordPress if
you're familiar with that normally at
least it has been the case with a lot of
content management systems that the
front-end what the users see right the
client-facing portion of it is tied
closely to the CMS so for instance in
WordPress you install WordPress and it
comes with these themes right so you can
change the themes right there from the
CMS and the theme is all the HTML and
CSS and everything that it usually going
to see when you go with a headless CMS
your website that the users see
interacts with the content management
system through an API so they're not
tied together and in our case what will
happen is the this the client the stuff
that the client sees that site which
we're going and react will be hosted on
an entirely different server than our
content management system so there'll be
no part of that content management
system that controls you know kind of
the look of the site so that's what we
mean by headless and you can run normal
CMS's as headless CMS's which which is
what we've done with WordPress several
times now and what we may end up doing
again for this project so anyway thanks
for asking that Blake so if anybody if I
ever use some terms that you're not
familiar with feel free to ask don't
worry if you know you think you might
look like a newbie or whatever but it
doesn't matter I would wrap much rather
you ask right off the bat then have to
go through the whole stream not
understanding what I'm saying and if you
don't know what the term is I bet you
there's other people watching that all
don't know what the term is and there'll
be people watching later on the
recordings that don't know so so please
ask okay cool hard [ __ ] I I got the link
here to that you put in here which is to
your blog so I'm gonna check that out
I'm put that in my browser right now
let's check that out when I can later on
nice very nice I just glanced at what
will popped up immediately and that's
looking really good hard [ __ ] okay okay
hard [ __ ] was mentioning using ghost for
his blog and says ghost uses markdown in
the editor that's actually really cool
if you're familiar with markdown that
would be really cool if you're not
familiar with markdown that might it
might be a little bit difficult but I
found it pretty easy to pick up on I'm
no expert at markdown but it's kind of
nice all right Steven says Jesse just a
shout-out to you running these streams
great job really shows how a programmer
works makes me feel better about looking
stuff up online all the time
awesome that's a that's what I wanted
from these streams right I want
everybody to see how much I mess up on
the job and and I must have to learn and
work through things so I'm glad that
that that's helping you feel better
about that but that's I mean that's what
we do right we we all these are
constantly learning as we go okay and
Stephan asked the same question about
the headless CMS so so great see I knew
there's more than one person that would
ask that
well rook says that back end looks like
bootstrap yeah bootstrap was used for
this for Keystone
okay
man who says my first OSS suggestion
ever being used by Jesse Keystone jazz
suggestion yes thank you man Oh like I
said there are definitely parts of
Keystone that I'm really impressed with
yeah definitely just I'm just kind of
hesitant about that about it not being
actively maintained now or at least
that's the appearance that I that I have
if anybody that works on Keystone is
watching or ever watches this please set
me straight if I'm wrong about that
or if anybody knows anyone ever hears
about a fork of Keystone that is being
actively maintained I'd love to see that
as well you know unless I hear about it
this week it's probably not going to be
what we use for this site because we got
to move on but I'd still like to check
it out and maybe even use it you know in
one of our projects later on if I can
see Oh Philip says how about apostrophe
CMS I I'll have to check that out I've
heard of that one as well also check
that out I'm getting a lot of
suggestions I'll definitely have to do
my research tomorrow morning and and
then we'll try out one of these other
JavaScript CMS's on the stream tomorrow
okay Philip says says my friend is using
strappy so Philip yeah I'd love to hear
how strap is going so if you happen to
talk to your friend at some point soon
you know ask about what they think about
strappy because I'd love to hear from
somebody who's actually using it all
right well um room says I have a request
will you take the chat screen to your
screen when you answer questions in chat
I want to see the chat watch the video
later thank you on room that's actually
a good idea and I did do that once
unfortunately when I did that somebody
typed in some things that weren't very
nice and kind of it ruined it so I'm not
I'm not going to do that and I really
wish I could do that but especially
since I'm streaming while I'm at work
for the university I just and it's on
behalf of free code camp I'd really
rather not have something crazy come up
in the chat I mean maybe I could go
through later on and like blur it out
but anybody that watched it live and
watches it you know until I get a chance
to go blur it out would see those things
so I don't want to get the pre-code camp
or my University in trouble with
anything so that's why I'm not going to
do it if I can think up or if any you
can think up some way that we could I
don't know protect against that then I'm
open to it
but until then I'll just do my best to
kind of read out what's in the chat so
anyway that's a really good suggestion I
said unfortunately somebody somebody
ruined that so I just you know I don't
want to expose you oh and you know
everybody else watching too any type of
you know craziness right hot in these
says exactly what I was about to ask
what key features made you choose
Keystone
yeah so basically I think I'm not gonna
choose Keystone officially but what
would led me to it at least to want to
try it was I saw that there were other
people that were using Keystone with
graph QL and we definitely want to use
graph QL I saw that it was completely
JavaScript base which I really liked
that it was all JavaScript that way we
can be full stack JavaScript and not
have to worry about burning another
language hey oh sorry yawning a lot yes
so those were the main things that
attracted me to key so I mean obviously
open source MIT license right I mean it
seemed like it was somewhat you know
easy to you know mess around with and
change so that's what attracted me to it
in the first place and it's I kept
seeing it when I would look up like
JavaScript CMS it would come up
frequently so I thought it was worth a
try
all right harsh it says you can block
offensive stuff in the settings I think
we're already blocking offensive things
but I mean there you can't block
everything right there are a lot of
things that won't get caught by those
filters so I mean I'm I'm open to
rethinking that if enough people think
it would be of a benefit to the stream
you know to have the chat up on the on
the screen like that I'll reconsider it
let me know and let me know what you all
think I'm just gonna have to be like
really vigilant about making sure that
things don't get in you know on the
stream you know I want to keep this
dream like Peno pg-rated you know this
you know young young people you know
watch this - you've had you know like
young kids and things watch this show
before so anyway I wouldn't I wouldn't
want to you know expose them to anything
that their parents wouldn't want them to
see alright cool man who says you ask
for suggestions in the first video for
CMS I remembered I'm feeling good about
this one of the life's goals
accomplished awesome well I'm glad
you're happy about I'm glad I can I
could help you accomplish one of your
life goals here all right Blake has to
go see you Blake yeah hopefully you'd be
back tomorrow and all right let's see
harsh harsh did I see the IP address you
just posted so I will check that out
okay jonbi says maybe a three code camp
to provide a moderator for the streams
or to potentially promote someone who
watches these a lot to do moderation
yeah okay I that's actually not a bad
idea I've thought about that before I
always just thought if we end up getting
a lot of people in the live chat that
would be useful so far it's always been
enough for me to handle but I'll think
about that all right well I have to go
now and and go over to my my meeting so
anyway thank you so much horse actually
horse should I see your project your
freelance project right now so I'm gonna
take a look at that but I just want to
let you know I saw it
okay I have to go now thank you so much
for watching I will most likely be back
tomorrow around 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
and we'll try out another JavaScript
content management system I will not be
testing content management systems later
than this week because we need to get
moving so we're going to make a decision
this week the sooner the better and then
we'll move on to some other stuff but
until then it's fun to test some things
out so again thank you all for watching
so glad for all the help and all the
suggestions that you all have given and
until tomorrow have a great day